I want to tell you about the future of
money let's start with a story about
this culture that lived in Micronesia in
the early 1900s called the Yap now I
want to tell you about the Yap because
their form of money is really
interesting they use these limestone
disks called rice tones now the Yap
don't actually move these rice tones
around or exchange them the way that we
do with our coins because rice tones can
get to be pretty massive the largest is
about four tons and twelve feet across
so the Yap just kind of keep track of
who owns what part of what stone now
there's a story about these sailors that
were transporting a stone across the
ocean when they ran into some trouble
and the stone actually fell in now the
sailors got back to the main island and
they told everyone what had happened and
everyone decided that actually yes the
sailors had the stone and why not it's
still counted even though it was at the
bottom of the ocean it was still part of
the Yap economy now you might think that
this was just a small culture a hundred
years ago but things like this happen in
the Western world as well and the Yap
actually still use a form of these
stones in 1932 the Bank of France asked
the United States to convert their
holdings from dollars into gold but it
was too inconvenient to actually think
about shipping all of that gold over to
Europe so instead someone went to where
that gold is being stored and they just
labeled it as belonging to France now
and everyone agreed that France owned
the gold it's just like those rise
stones the point I want to make with
these two examples is that there's
nothing inherently valuable about a
dollar or a stone or coin the only
reason that these things have any value
is because we've all decided that they
and because we've decided that they do
money is about the exchanges and the
transactions that we have with each
other money isn't anything objective
it's about a collective story that we
tell each other about value a collective
fiction and that's a really powerful
concept in the past two decades we've
begun to use digital money so I get paid
via direct deposit I pay my rent via
bank transfer I pay my taxes online and
every month a small amount of money is
deducted from my paycheck and invested
in mutual funds in my retirement account
all of these interactions are literally
just changing ones and zeroes on
computers there's not even anything
physical like a stone or a coin digital
money makes it so that I can pay someone
around the world in seconds now when
this works it's because there are large
institutions underwriting everyone or
zero that changes on a computer and when
it doesn't it's often the fault of those
large institutions or at least it's up
to them to fix the problem and a lot of
times they don't there's a lot of
friction in the system how long does it
take the US credit card companies to
implement chip-and-pin half my credit
cards still don't work in Europe
that's friction transferring money
across borders and across currencies is
really expensive friction an
entrepreneur in India can set up an
online business in minutes but it's hard
for her to get loans and to get paid
friction our access to digital money and
our ability to freely transact is being
held captive by these gatekeepers and
there's a lot of impediments in the
system slowing things down
that's because digital money isn't
really mine it's entries and databases
that belong to my bank my credit card
company or my investment firm
and these companies have the right to
say no if I'm a PayPal merchant and
PayPal wrongly Flags me for fraud that's
it my account gets frozen and I can't
get paid these institutions are standing
in the way of innovation how many of you
use Facebook photos
Google photos Instagram my photos are
everywhere they are on my phone they're
on my laptop they're on my old phone
they're in Dropbox they're on all these
different websites and services and most
of these services don't work together
they don't interoperate and as a result
my photo library is a mess now the same
thing happens when institutions control
the money supply a lot of these services
don't interoperate and as a result this
blocks what we can do with payment and
it makes transaction costs go up so far
we've been through two phases of money
in an analog world we had to deal with
these physical objects and money moved
at a certain speed the speed of humans
in a digital world money can reach much
farther and is much faster but we're at
the mercy of these gatekeeper
institutions money only moves at the
speed of banks we're about to enter a
new phase of money the future of money
is programmable when we combine software
and currency money becomes more than
just a static unit of value and we don't
have to rely on institutions for
security in a programmable world we
remove humans and institutions from the
loop and when this happens we won't even
feel like we're transacting anymore
money will be directed by software and
it will just safely and securely flow
crypto currencies are the first step
of this evolution cryptocurrencies are
digital money that isn't run by any
government or any bank it's money
designed to work in a world without
intermediaries bitcoin is the most
ubiquitous cryptocurrency but there are
hundreds of them there's a theory 'm
litecoin stellar dogecoin and those are
just a few of the more popular ones and
these things are real money the sushi
restaurant down my street takes Bitcoin
I have an app on my phone that I can use
to buy sashimi but it's not just for
small transactions in March there was a
transaction that moved around a hundred
thousand bitcoins that's the equivalent
of 40 million u.s. dollars crypto
currencies are based on a special field
of mathematics called cryptography
cryptography is the study of how to
secure communication and it's about two
really important things
masking information so it can be hidden
in plain sight and verifying a piece of
information source cryptography
underpins so many of the systems around
us and it's so powerful that at times
the US government has actually
classified it as a weapon during World
War two breaking crypto systems like
enigma was critical to decoding enemy
transmissions and turning the tide of
the war today anyone with a modern web
browser is running a pretty
sophisticated crypto system it's what we
use to secure our interactions on the
Internet it's what makes it safe for us
to type our passwords in and to send
financial information to websites so
what the bank's used to give us
trustworthy digital money transfer we
can now get with a clever application of
cryptography and this means that we
don't have to rely on the banks anymore
to secure our transactions we can do it
ourselves Bitcoin is based on the very
same idea that the Yap used this
collective global knowledge of transfers
in Bitcoin I
Bend by transferring Bitcoin and I get
paid when someone transfers Bitcoin to
me imagine that we had this magic paper
so the way that this paper works is I
can give you a sheet of it and if you
write something on it it'll magically
appear on my piece as well now let's say
we just give everyone this paper and
everyone writes down the transfers that
they're doing in the Bitcoin system all
of these transfers get copied around to
everyone else's pieces of paper and I
can look at mine and I'll have a list of
all of the transfers that are happening
in the entire Bitcoin economy this is
actually what's happening with the
Bitcoin blockchain which is a list of
all of the transactions in Bitcoin
except it's not done through paper it's
done through computer code running on
thousands of networked computers around
the world all of these computers are
collectively confirming who owns what
Bitcoin so the Bitcoin blockchain is
core to how Bitcoin works but where do
bitcoins actually come from well the
code is designed to create new Bitcoin
according to a schedule and the way that
it works is that to get those Bitcoin I
have to solve a puzzle a random
cryptographic puzzle imagine that we had
15 dice and we were throwing these dice
over and over again whenever the dice
come up all sixes we say that we win
this is very close to what these
computers are all actually doing they're
trying over and over again to land on
the right number and when they do we say
that they've solved the puzzle the
computer that solves the puzzle
publishes its solution to the rest of
the network and collects its reward new
bitcoins and in the act of solving this
puzzle these computers are actually
helping to secure the Bitcoin blockchain
and add to the list of transactions now
there are actually people all over the
world running this software and we call
them Bitcoin
anyone can become a Bitcoin miner you
can go download the software right now
and run it on your computer and try to
collect some bitcoins I can't say that I
would recommend it because right now the
puzzle is so hard and the network is so
powerful that if I tried to mine Bitcoin
on my laptop I probably wouldn't see any
for about two million years the miners
professional miners use this special
hardware that's designed to solve the
puzzle really fast now
the Bitcoin network and all of this
special hardware there are estimates
that the amount of energy it uses is
equivalent to that of a small country so
the first set of crypto currencies are a
little bit slow and a little bit
cumbersome but the next generation is
going to be so much better and so much
faster cryptocurrencies are the first
step to a world with a global
programmable money and in a world with
programmable money I can pay anyone else
securely without having to sign up or
ask permission or do a conversion or
worry about my money
getting stuck and I can send money
around the world this is a really
amazing thing it's this idea of
permissionless innovation the internet
caused an explosion of innovation
because it was built upon an open
architecture and just like the internet
changed the way we communicate
programmable money is going to change
the way we pay allocate and decide on
value so what kind of world is
programmable money create well imagine a
world where I can rent out my healthcare
data to a pharmaceutical company they
can run large-scale data analysis and
provide me with a cryptographic proof
that shows that they're only using my
data in a way that we agreed and they
can pay me for what they find out
instead of signing up for streaming
services and getting a cable bill what
if my television analyzed my watching
habits and recommended well priced
content that fit within my budget that I
would enjoy imagine an internet without
ads because instead of paying with our
attention when we view content we just
pay interestingly things like micro
payments are actually going to change
the way security works in our world
because once we're better able to
allocate value people will use their
money and their energies for more
constructive things if it costs a
fraction of a cent to send an email
would we still have spam or not at this
world yet but it's coming right now it's
like we're in a world that's seeing the
first automobile the first
cryptocurrency like the first car is
slow and hard to understand and hard to
use digital money like the horse and
carriage works pretty well and the whole
world economy is built on it if you were
the first person on your block to get a
car with an internal combustion engine
your neighbors would probably think you
were crazy why would you want this large
clunky machine that breaks down all the
time that lights on fire and is still
slower than a horse but we all know how
that story turns out we're entering a
new era of programmable money and it's
very exciting but it's also a little bit
scary cryptocurrencies can be used for
legal transactions just like cash is
used for crime in the world today when
all of our transactions are online what
does that mean for surveillance who can
see what we do whose advantage in this
new world and who isn't well I have to
start to pay for things that I didn't
have to pay for before well we all
become slaves to algorithms and utility
functions all new technology comes with
trade-offs the internet brought us a lot
of ways to waste time but it also
greatly increased productivity mobile
phones are annoying because they make me
feel like I have to stay connected to
work all the
time but they also help me stay
connected to friends and family the new
sharing economy is going to eliminate
some jobs but it's also going to create
new flexible forms of employment with
programmable money we decouple the need
for large trusted institutions from the
architecture of the network and this
pushes innovation in money out to the
edges where it belongs programmable
money democratizes money and because of
this things are going to change and
unfold in ways that we can't even
predict thank you